Napoléon en même temps il gagne des
batailles en même temps le gouverne
l'Europe et on sait et en même temps
pardon mesdemoiselles et mesdames ils
baisent bon
soir oui on va boire un coup dans la
cuisine en attendant nos amis
asseyez-vous
Henry charnels
mais quelquefois je reviens de
l'Académie à pied je viens de l'Académie
c'est-à-dire du fait conquis jusqu'à la
forme à pied exprès jusqu'à la Porte
Dauphine
à pied je marche beaucoup en tous les
cas moi vous m'avez fait un grand
plaisir je vous en parle à chaque fois
que je vous vois
la préface que vous avez fait de mon
livre c'est très content parce que j'ai
senti une véritable foi vous imaginez
mes parents
fait un livre avec une préface d'Alain
Decaux
à le faire parce qu'il y avait là
vraiment quelqu'un qui croyait cette
cause et pourquoi pas les arguments sont
pas démodés du tout parce que vous savez
que tout le monde a pris ça à l'époque
pour une pause de dandy mais en fait pas
du tout parce que c'était en 86 ça fait
pratiquement 20 ans ça fait 19 ans et je
propais toujours les mêmes arguments sur
la monarchie
les fameux traités
en Europe à la vôtre
vous écrivez sur quoi un livre secret
parce que maintenant je n'annonce plus
mes livres parce qu'en fait les idées
pas du tout parce que il y a quelques
années j'avais commencé un livre j'avais
indiqué le sujet à mon éditeur lequel
l'a fait passer un petit communiqué dans
la presse et puis on a su que j'écrivais
ce livre mais moi arrivé au bout de 300
pas je me suis dit ce sujet nul je me
suis complètement trompé j'arrête je
n'ai jamais plus publié ce livre alors
maintenant je ne dis plus à personne ce
que je fais avant que ce soit fini la
télévision alors
à la télévision c'est rayé ma vie je
l'ai fait délibérément j'ai aussi vous
savez quitté la radio
pour les raisons très simples
opérations et mon cardiologue m'a dit et
la phrase est très belle je vous
interdis maintenant les stress
d'obligation
vous étiez napoléoniste quand même non
j'étais très napolé la colonie
de très bonnes relations des relations
vraiment le droit d'amitié avec le
dernier point de s'aperon qui nous
aimerait bien et il y a quelques années
et sache que j'aime beaucoup sa femme
est une femme admirable et oui mais je
n'étais pas bonapartiste d'ailleurs le
prince invalent lui-même n'était pas
bonne partie jamais parce qu'il était
intelligent
Napoléon 4
parce que vous savez qu'il voulait tous
vous rencontrer alors pourquoi vous dire
rencontrer absolument Alain Decaux alors
Jean-Paul parce que on écrit d'arrêter
d'être comique d'être historien et vous
l'êtes vous l'êtes et tout ce qui est
dans le livre et rigoureusement exact je
comprends pas pourquoi vous vous n'avez
jamais parlé de tout ça
je vais vous dire la vérité tout ce que
vous avez écrit je le sais et depuis
longtemps je sais que tout ce que vous
écrivez est vrai mais je ne pouvais pas
le dire grâce à vous enfin
bien je peux dire la vérité elle est
dans votre livre les chasseurs la
définition est très évident c'est
laquelle va être la définition château
fort si je te rappelle la définition du
château j'ai mon ouvrage sur moi je vais
au Moyen-Âge parce que je crois que les
châteaux forts
les châteaux forts
elle se rend compte de ce qu'elle m'a
Michel il a fait signer je voudrais
montrer à mes convives la page en
question voilà parce
que rien voilà pour son argent il y a
pas que des lettres
alors voilà et donc on explique pour la
différence entre le château et le
château fort le château fort est tout
simplement beaucoup plus costaud alors
que le château est beaucoup moins
costaud
maintenant ce que j'ai créé partout
voilà il faut absolument que les
vieilles se rallye il vous attribué il
vous aura attribué une préface qui est
quand même quelque chose oui on ne s'est
vu dans l'obligation de faire un fond la
préface c'est au début c'est au début
mais tu vois tu l'as eu à l'aise
tous les trucs du mec qui écrit un
bouquin quoi
après il y a un avant-propos ça c'est
pas la préface
c'est moi je bosse à la télé en même
temps alors
messieurs J'ai le regret de refuser
votre demande de préface car votre
ouvrage comporte de nombreuses insectes
notamment à la page
il y a quatre lignes de pages de fautes
je me vois dans l'obligation de porter
plainte auprès de votre éditeur pour sa
cage de patrimoine culturel français
mais y accéder mais consternants de
salutations signées Alain Decaux avec un
S avec un S mais c'est pour ça que j'ai
un argument pour mon procès en plus on
me prête un nom qui n'est pas le mien je
sais qu'il a fait une salade
d'un livre pour moi oui oui
un livre d'histoire mais sérieux et il a
demandé la préface et bien que
bonapartiste
napoléoni napoléoniste la distinction
entre bonapartie c'est napoléonien s'il
vous plaît
à mon avis c'est difficile de pas faire
de papa ne vient pas l'admirer mais en
revanche c'est pas on n'est pas partisan
du haut à la restauration de l'Empire et
la différence entre vaginien et
vaginiste c'est un peu les mêmes gens
quand j'étais enfant à guéri il y avait
un parti Bonaparte avec des structures
avec avec un comité qui se réunissait
les derniers descendants oui ils sont
disparus il y a pas si longtemps
mais en tout cas parmi les descendants
Napoléon il y a un grand généalogiste
que j'ai connu qui n'est plus
malheureusement qui s'appelait Joseph
valencel qui a fait des travaux mais qui
débouchent sur des choses
extraordinaires il montre parmi les
descendants de Napoléon c'est un livre
qui apparaît qui est Paris à 20 ans que
l'un d'eux est passionnant dans le métro
c'est vrai c'est parfaitement vrai c'est
pas déjà
l'histoire du conte Léon oui c'est un
descendant du compte Léon
alors le compte client je t'explique
Napoléon est marié avec Joséphine il
peut pas avoir d'enfant et à ce
moment-là Joséphine qui avait eu deux
enfants hortense et le prince Eugène dit
à Napoléon c'est toi qui peux pas avoir
d'enfant puisque moi j'en ai eu deux
avant toi et toi tu en as jamais eu et
la sœur de Napoléon c'est le capitaine à
l'Élysée je crois que c'est Pauline non
oui Pauline qui dit à Napoléon écoute on
va faire un essai je vais te prêter une
copine tu vas voir si tu si tu peux la
mettre enceinte on va voir si ça vient
de toi ou si ça vient de ta femme c'est
bien l'impératrice
ça vient de Joséphine et donc Napoléon
fait un enfant à cette situation c'est
une dame de compagnie oui mademoiselle
de La de nouvelles de menu exactement et
donc il lui fait un enfant
et cet enfant évidemment la fille lui
demande de le reconnaître il refuse de
reconnaître l'enfant mais il accepte
quand même que l'enfant s'appelle Léon
il lui donne la moitié de son nom et cet
enfant le conte Léon a traversé tout le
XIXe siècle et quand il y a une Napoléon
III au pouvoir évidemment il était très
riche évidemment puisque son oncle lui
donner de l'argent mais quand après il y
a eu la fin du Second Empire il avait
plus d'argent donc à la fin du 19e
siècle dans certains bistrots de
Montmartre on voyait le le compte Léon
avec un chapeau sur la tête la main
comme ça et on lui donnait du pognon sur
les mecs dans le bistrot lui il avait
fait nous Napoléon soit sympa c'était
pas fini parce que il y a eu un compte
néon de notre temps avant on le
reconnaissait comme le descendant de
l'empereur et signé tellement
d'orthographe qu'un beau jour il a il
est un aile jusqu'à signer des tickets
de métro parce qu'il y avait plus de
panel et l'histoire est parfaitement du
contraire
et ça je trouve ça merveilleux vous
savez que l'abeille était ainsi de
Napoléon et il était à petit
dans la misère en fait le premier
conduit le premier oui oui
le compte client
j'ai découvert il y a peu de temps une
phrase de Victor Hugo qui me hante parce
qu'il se trouve que j'ai aussi la foi et
cette phrase est la suivante je le crois
pas qu'une prière puisse se perdre
l'homme qui dit cela n'est pas baptisé
il n'est pas catholique il n'est donc
aucune religion il dira à sa mort je
refuse les prières des religions je les
demande à tous les hommes et ben je dis
que cette phrase est formée à moi elle
m'aide
bien la fin Napoléon Napoléon il était
croyant Alain Napoléon
repose sur les bords de la Seine dans
ces pays que j'ai tenté mais il a reçu
l'extrême-onction mais je pense que
c'était politique
je pense qu'il voulait pour montrer au
monde qu'il était mort dans le foie je
sentais testament je meurs dans la
religion catholique catholique et
romaine dans laquelle je suis né donc
c'est un élément empêché de faire
déplacer
qu'il était politique jusqu'à la mort
oui c'est incroyable ça absolument puis
tout ce qu'il a fait à Sainte-Hélène et
politique quand il va vendre son
argenterie qui l'a rapporté le Paris
c'est de l'argent massif c'est c'est une
argenterie qui vaut beaucoup d'argent
qui est formelle il a été mis dans ses
bagarres il a emporté tout cela
et il va la vendre pourquoi est-ce qu'il
a vend il assimilion dans 6000 euros
dans une banque de Paris chez Lafitte et
ça y est et c'est ce qui permettra de
faire l'élève qui va faire assez fidèles
et il la vend pour que tous les médias à
l'époque on dit les journaux du monde
disent Napoléon réduit à se vendre par
l'Angleterre
la façon la plus extraordinaire dont
était pétries l'argile humaine
c'est-à-dire des chateaubriands
est-ce que c'est pas l'homme le plus
étonnant qui est jamais existé moi je
pense toujours à une phrase de Pascal
Pascal qui parle des esprits peut pas
parler
mais il dit il existe des esprits vastes
et moi je dis cette phrase s'applique à
la fois
c'est un esprit vaste quand on regarde
tout ce qu'il écrit on va on va rééditer
ça correspondant et moi j'ai un
exemplaire du Second Empire la
correspondance de de la Polo et il y a
13 ou 17 volumes on l'ouvre au hasard on
dit comment ce type là a pu tous les
jours écrire tout ça dicter souvent il y
a quatre semaines
mais il le fait et en même temps il
gagne des batailles en même temps il
gouverne l'Europe et on sait et en même
temps pardon mesdemoiselle et mesdames
ils baisent bon alors merci
Jean-Louis le mot volontairement je
l'avais prévu à l'avance je dirais il
baise certains pour montrer qu'elle a
que des missions français est capable en
public de dire il pète
il y a une chose
un souvenir que j'ai il avait le
déjeunions un soir chez moi avec André
Froissart
j'avais rencontré Dieu dans une église
et aussi
alors il voit j'ai ça tienne la place
l'accord responsable de la pôle emploi
il s'approche et dit ah bon j'ai dit bah
oui et dis à quoi ça sert d'avoir la
correspondance de la parole j'ai dit
chez André vous prenez un volume au
hasard et vous regardez il prend au
hasard il ouvre
ah oui et quel modernité j'ai dit
pourquoi vous dit ça et il me fait lire
Monsieur Le Grand Maréchal je vais
rentrer en campagne d'hiver je tiens à
ce que mes armées sont soit abondamment
équipés de capotes
ce qu'on sait pas sur la scène du sac
c'est qu'en fait il avait des il avait
fait avec des marionnettes
du sacre avec des mannequins quoi
comme ça vous savez pas ça
[Musique]
parce que franchement tu vois finalement
ceux de quoi c'est
Mitterrand il faut avoir lu les
souvenirs de son frère aîné Robert qui
raconte leur enfance commune etc ils
viennent de province ils sont dans une
maison religieuse pour faire leurs
études supérieures
et là ils vont à la messe presque chaque
jour et Robert ses mémoires c'est
naturellement journal il a aménagé parce
qu'il peut pas souvenir de temps de
détails et dit je vois je vois Frédéric
pas Frédéric je vois François
de la table sainte et j'admire la
manière dont il rentre pénétrer jusqu'au
fond de l'âme parce qu'il vient de
ressentir alors bien sûr il a évolué il
a il a
il n'est plus devenu le même homme mais
je me demande si quand on a vécu ça on
peut tout évacuer je crois pas je peux
vous dire que non
merci moi je suis l'exemple j'ai été
élevé chez l'écureuil j'ai tout renié
tout abandonné j'ai craché sur tout et à
l'âge de 40 ans c'est revenu sans que
j'y puisse rien
il y a des gens qui savent pas
c'est revenu quand j'ai connu de grandes
difficultés dans la vie
et d'un seul coup je me suis raccroché à
je me suis raccroché à je me suis pas
raccroché la religion m'a aidé à ce
moment-là mais c'est revenu de l'enfance
de très très loin ça revient mais le
fait que un jour où j'allais à l'Élysée
j'ai passé pas ma vie mais il se trouve
que je demande du Conseil de la
Francophonie
j'y allais parce que c'était le ciel
qu'est-ce que je vois sortir par une
porte comme dirait Hugo dérobée et je
vois j'en guide
mon cher ami qu'est-ce que vous faites
là du jour on visite à quelqu'un de
temps à eau et j'ai su que c'était
Mitterrand qui voulait voir Jean Guitton
avec cette question étrange il espérait
que Jean gitan philosophe chrétien lui
prouverait que Dieu existe et Jean dit
tant essayé mais
lui-même
un homme de foi a des doutes vous savez
moi je pense toujours à ce qu'a écrit
les gens André Morrois dans un livre
complètement oublié qu'ils appelaient me
pour la délivrant dialogue entre celui
qui est à la fois et pas
celui qui n'a pas la foi alors vous avez
la foi oui
mais alors vous devez quand même douter
une fois par jour
celui qui a la foi pas du tout ah bon et
alors 100 fois par jour mais oui l'homme
qui a la foi qui ne douterait pas je
trouve ça bizarre je pense que le pape
doute je pense que c'est insensé de dire
ça mais je pense que il n'est pas
possible de ne pas douter ces choses là
sont pas certaines
questions
à laquelle j'avais personne à trouver
une réponse c'est à dire que j'ai écrit
pour les enfants des livres parce que
j'avais envie de faire des livres pour
les enfants parce que j'avais moi-même
des enfants moi Jésus-Christ raconte aux
enfants écrit par vous
c'est la Bible aussi et je l'ai fait à
l'envers
et là bon j'ai écrit ce que je pensais
que on savait au point de vue historique
et c'est tout reste quoi il en reste
beaucoup parce que la Bible hébraïque
reflète un certain qui sont historiques
elles reflètent aussi la croyance d'un
peuple pendant des siècles et des
siècles c'est très important et c'est là
où je me suis rendu compte que le
christianisme je redémarre en compte
plutôt et réellement l'héritier du
judaïsme dans le droit fil dans le
totalement doit-il ce que les cresses
parce que Jésus était juif j'ai fait
dactylographie au manuscrit sur Jésus à
quelqu'un un homme charmant qui avait
été dans l'armée qui avait été champion
de dactylographie dans l'armée
très vite et il me dit mais comment
Jésus était juif
j'ai dit oui vous le saviez pas non non
non pas du tout
vous pensiez quoi
[Rires]
j'ai dit mais il était vive tout alors
quand j'ai ajouté pendant plus de 10 ans
il n'y a eu de chrétiens que des Juifs
parce que après la mort de Jésus les
premiers chrétiens
c'est convertir leurs frais ils disaient
le Messie était annoncé nous on sait
qu'on l'a eu il faut qu'on le dise à nos
frais et ça n'est qu'au bout de plus de
10 ans que saint Paul c'est pour ça que
j'ai écrit sur lui saint Paul lui a
pensé qu'il était temps d'en parler aux
autres à ceux qu'on appelait les païens
et ça a été très dur parce que les les
juifs chrétiens un peu un peu
intégrésistes il faut bien le dire à
l'origine vous voulez pas qu'on aille
parler ou payant c'était entre nous
cette affaire là et on est allé chez les
païens le Christian
une simple observation elle va pas elle
va pas très loin et c'est une simple
inverse je dis dans la messe catholique
d'aujourd'hui il y a des textes que
obligatoirement dans toutes les
paroisses du monde on doit dire ça
commence par un extrait de la biberique
un prophète Isaïe ou un autre donc juif
ça suit par un texte de saint Paul juif
ça continue par un évangile les quatre
évangélistes sont juifs donc la Mestre
catholique est entre des temps il y a
des uns psaume le psaume est juif la
messe catholique est entièrement faite
sur des textes juifs et la plupart de
ceux qui vont ne savent pas
l'antisémitisme du 19e siècle et du
début du 20e c'est absurde absolument
absurde justement de replacer Jésus dans
dans son judaïsme est-ce qu'il était
est-ce qu'il était rabbin est-ce qu'il
était est-ce qu'il a eu un frère est-ce
que son frère était Jacques
etc etc
je pense que c'est démontré aujourd'hui
pour remarquable d'un historien de
religion juive de formation juive Bernal
qui a écrit une démonstration
éblouissante sur le fait que Jacques le
premier évêque chrétien était le frère
de Jésus
c'est incroyable comme certains bouquins
qu'on pourrait appeler un peu de gars
comme DaVinci code on crée tout un tas
de remous et tout un tas de recherches
et tout d'un coup il y a d'autres
recherches beaucoup plus scientifiques
qui ont vu le jour et qu'on a pu voir la
télévision et on a commencé à
s'intéresser à s'intéresser à tout ça et
là en ce moment il y a des choses qui
sortent on sait que Ben que peut-être il
a eu il a eu une femme en tout cas
qu'une femme la compagnie que sa mère
donc sa mère a mis au monde un frère
donc il y a plusieurs
frères donc automatiquement elle a pas
fait ça toute seule voilà il y a plein
de choses qui sont qui sont là en
gestation qui sont plutôt vraiment
intéressantes et qui vont qui devrait
qui devrait être que rapprocher le
judaïsme le christianisme doivent se la
même chose tout à fait mais c'est ce que
Jean-Paul II a on peut reconnaître
synagogue de la synagogue de demander
pardon et tout faut c'est qu'il faut je
suis d'accord avec vous
avec une seule caméra on est d'accord
une seule comme ça attention il y avait
quand même des illustrations
il y a pas de rentrer donc si vous
apprenez tout par cœur avant j'apprenais
rien j'écrivais même pas compte non je
faisais je ne remplissais la tête je
m'en remplissais la tête
un mois un mois de lecture sur le sujet
après quoi dans la semaine qui précédait
je faisais un plan en disant je vais
dire ça dans l'ordre ce plan était
réduit qui était d'abord assez important
et aurait été réduit en une seule page
la veille de l'émission et le matin
l'émission et là l'après-midi j'arrivais
à 4h je voyais mon équipe et je leur
donnais le texte qui était manuscrit ça
avait été fait on le photocopie pour les
distribuer à toute l'équipe et là je ne
faisais pas la répétition parce que je
l'avais fait au début
et au début j'avais répété on avait
ensuite fait l'émission en direct et le
régisseur qui était dans la cabine tout
à fait en haut m'a dit ah c'était
surtout bien cet après-midi à Monsieur
Decaux je dis pourquoi vous dites ça
parce que c'était le mieux cet
après-midi alors j'ai dit allô
Jean-Charles on ne répétera plus jamais
ils auront le pop votre anecdote
concorde avec ce que Dominique notre
ancien patron nous avait balancé une
fois en répétition en répéter nos sketch
l'après-midi et il passait et il nous
disait ce soir vous serez à chier et on
disait mais comment tu le sais il disait
parce que là vous étiez bon
il y a une règle et un jour un jour vous
avez été dérangé par quelque chose mais
c'est le seul fois que vous avez eu un
trou j'ai eu un trou terrible parce que
c'était le moment où on a voulu me
changer de caméra sous mes yeux moi je
regardais l'objectif
la dernière l'objectif il y avait
heureusement quelques millions de
personnes et je savais qu'elles étaient
là ces gens quand des groupes m'a dit
qu'il faut que tu enregistres parce
qu'on va ajouter des images etc je les
fais parce qu'il le voulait mais cela
dit j'ai regrettais le direct parce que
je sentais avec le dirige je sentais ce
genre qui était là très fort et je leur
parlais tout à coup vient me mettre une
nouvelle caméra on la change tous mes
vieux horreur absolue et alors quand le
cadreur change de caméra prend la
nouvelle parce que c'est la première
était en panne et qui passe de l'autre
côté et quand il me fait comme ça
c'est à dire comment on regarde on va
quitter la première fois
je sais plus ce que je fais une fois une
fois une fois une fois non franchement
vous en veux pas
à l'Académie vous en êtes à quelle
lettre elle académie nous sommes à la
lettre eh groove je suis entré à la
lettre F en
1980 c'est incroyable c'est-à-dire vous
en êtes avec
il faut un dictionnaire ils sont pas
pressés
la 9e édition du dictionnaire en 2010 et
vous discutez à beaucoup
l'Académie c'est plutôt rigolo parce que
sur les définitions on parle du
dictionnaire précédent nous sommes à la
neuvième édition il y en a eu 9 depuis
1635 bon on travaille sur l'ancien
et en seulement quels sont les mots
qu'il faut expulser parce que il ne se
parle plus du tout c'est un travail
inquiétant parce que se dit est-ce
qu'ils sont vraiment expulsés est-ce
qu'il y a encore des gens qui le disent
mais il y a une enquête qui est faite
pour nous par des spécialistes qui
lisent tous les journaux qui toutes les
émissions qui nous font un rapport en
disant honnêtement depuis 15 ans ce
monde n'a jamais plus été prononcé en
revanche je peux vous dire que alors
notre rôle encore plus difficile et
d'accepter des mots nouveaux parce que
les mots nouveaux naissent fatalement du
peuple Inès dans la rue et on fabrique
pas les mots nouveaux ils viennent comme
ça c'est l'argot au début et alors il se
passe des années et à force de faire de
la gauche quand même le monde alors il
faut décider qui doit entrer et là il y
a une responsabilité quand même c'est
une vraie responsabilité d'en faire
sortir
les ripoux c'est les pourrie pour les
policiers mais dans les journaux
d'accord parce que je trouve que les
ripoux est entré dans la lampe vous avez
dans les journaux le commissaire entre
elles convaincu d'être ripoux on dit pas
qu'on veut plus d'être pourri c'est très
complètement dans la langue alors là on
les prend on prend les mots qui sont
nouveaux alors c'est très amusant parce
que on discute entre nous il y a les
conservateurs qui disent jamais ce
mot-là doit être conservé pour l'avenir
il est beau Balzac là utiliser c'est
vrai que virer des mots du dictionnaire
c'est responsabilité quand même mais il
faut les virer puisqu'ils n'ont pas du
tout
Richelieu
de consacrer l'usage nous sommes obligés
de dire quels sont les mots dans l'usage
un jour un jour on présente à l'Académie
c'est le jeudi après-midi le mot un port
export alors définition
l'imaginez bien et puis bon nous on se
dit bon personne ne dit rien mais du
tout demande la parole il faut dire que
on est des copains pour la plupart on se
voit on se tutoie depuis 20 ans mais on
se dit Monsieur et vous alors du Tour du
monsieur le directeur on y passe tous on
est élu pour trois mois chacun est
directeur
ils sont richesse
alors Monsieur le Directeur je vais vous
dire une chose
j'apprends que vous acceptez que nous
acceptons à Paris et oui du directeur de
personne n'a branché Monsieur le
Directeur
j'ai parcouru une longue vie
j'ai
éprouvé de grands malheur c'est vrai
qu'il a été fait prisonnier il le dit
qui s'était Vadé
il a eu des malheureux intimes sa fille
est morte elle ne dit pas mais on pense
tous et dit voilà PAF tous les malheurs
je ne pensais pas à l'âge où je suis
parvenu que sous le portrait du cardinal
de Richelieu notre
on nous proposerait un port
extrême deux approfillations qui ne font
pas un mot et là tout le monde est
bouleversé
le directeur
quand Pascal avant il y a la Commission
du dictionnaire qui siège quelques jours
avant quelques semaines avant et qui est
présente les choses à la compagnie
dites quand la Commission du
dictionnaire assiégée nous avons été
unanime à dire un peu export n'est pas
tolérable et nous allons le rayer et
quelqu'un a dit d'entre nous
gardons-le jusqu'à la semaine prochaine
ce sera l'occasion d'une excellente
intervention monsieur
c'est trop alors est-ce que vous avez
pensé à écrire une pièce comique
là-dessus là sur sur
des mots
c'est payé c'est payé l'Académie oui oui
je crois qu'on gagne actuellement je
parle en France par mois
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de tube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu